bring it in yeah and cut the last shot
thank you so much for making my vision
of home alone finally come true meet new
people are you okay
I wanted to do my interpretation of a
Christmas classic Paul Malone really I
feel like there's so many new directions
you can take a story like that but
Hollywood doesn't understand my vision
perfect
hey here we are the old days we got a
cast member back and get rid of
everything not the sex
I don't know what's so incredible we put
the whole entire studio in these three
boxes and I think it was tough but they
had everything in there man yeah we had
it this is truly impressive are you
gonna figure out where you where is
Tamara I see thank you oh it's so empty
in here do you mind
okay greggers
is for you weaker boyfriend Gregory is
bodyguard area too close here we are
best audition they never got here we are
and here we go
look at this it's gone
we just keeps us all right it's our
young Google and we just came to the
studio this morning everyone stores like
I'm just in time is the Grinch the
Christmas Grinch you guys are so strong
[Laughter]
what have you been doing for four years
since I've been gone take this back dan
was in the bathroom it's all about you
Ellen no way seen sister joy you've been
doing
it was that guy oh that's so fun we got
him I am so behind on this I'm so sorry
this is hard I thought Malcolm is it's
difficult very difficult
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
you know I'm actually gonna miss this
place so many pleasant memories really
and before you get into here you wanna
really let's do this you'll start here
and you'll come in
okay for a partnership you scream we
wait like two seconds into that scream
and then we're running this or screaming
uh you're right as soon as I get to
three where both of us are gonna start
screaming and you can both run it but
you scream like maybe on the first step
you take soon as you take a step as we
start screen you want to throw it so we
can make sure they don't go out of frame
yeah okay yeah sure where you guys are
gonna be no Malcolm's getting he's
already played the devil so this is
actually pretty easy for him to do yeah
I mean I funny enough I don't know the
wide spectrum of Satanist I don't know
how many varieties there her heart the
idea of it I mean yeah I don't know yeah
but the devil knows that's why you
should join well that's going on we have
our other lovely array of serial killers
out here almost as silly as Rob Walker
is John Wayne Gacy just hipster John
Wayne Gacy cowboy this is now makes
sense there's gonna be Charles Manson
haha mr. Charles Manson they we got he's
somewhere in there I don't know and
Kevin
some great Trump hair going on there
yeah although that's much more hair than
Trump ass and what I like this is the
first cabinet has holes in the knees
anyway Rachel as that beatnik character
from goofy movie - I like to point out
by the way there is no cigarette in that
cigarette holder Jim offered to pull one
in I thought it was so much funnier with
that one no you know be perfect bubbles
came out of that - this is what we do
every time and we wait for Malcolm but
this time it's not his fault he's
getting made you're so impressed just
whoever he is just he's a Satanist I'll
just say stereotypical Satanist because
sister well are there different
divisions either it's like I don't know
just the crazy people that go hand the
Rosemary's Baby saying this whatever
those are clearly Tamra just took a seat
in the spot where I first interviewed
yeah and I just came in Emily hey so
how's it going my hair was like
legitimately this short was
it's so long yeah it was like a pixie
cut yeah yeah
not nearly as stunning as this look
right here beautiful stunning glamorous
pleco is she sorry are we all going to
the Oscars this Gilbert Gottfried yeah
the flag but then he said something
naughty on Twitter yeah that was more
rare it's like I have seven friends it
was hilarious
[Applause]
spicy wood wonderful I think I got what
I need from here continue watching that
brilliant version of Nutcracker
oh one more if you can no pause that
they're just wonderful I think I got
what I needed
go right into it all right whenever
you're ready
wonderful I think I got what I need from
you here all right who's ready for the
cannibal scene do we actually find all
fingers in this fingers missing
yeah mommy don't act like you're busy I
just like that I spent the entire time
at Brad's phone running away from clowns
and now you've become that night escape
can't escape I'm not afraid of clowns
I'm not afraid of clowns honestly after
doing Brad's movie I'm just like yeah
okay maybe I'm a little friend of cons
there are a couple like wow there were a
couple scenes where like this one dude
in particular was supposed to jump up
and I was supposed to like shoot him
basically but so the director Ryan gets
all set up like right behind me and he's
like and then Rob and like he was like a
good like 15 feet away at the time like
getting naked put on his and so Ryan's
like director he's like sin robbed
you're just gonna turn around and then
aim your gun in so I turned around like
this and the dude was like right here
God scare I had unsaid words like oh you
did yeah you told me that because most
people I was kind of like it's alright
there was a hunter you yeah
yeah we screamed like little girls when
it happened - I'm pretty sure it's on
the first viewing yeah this is some real
Return to Oz freaky show going on in
this movie is still in theaters this
novice ki motley oh okay I thought
you're talking about the recent mess
cracker no no that's just some shitty
timbre Tanaka oh this was on a whole
other level
yeah also you acted for her to start the
line then when she you know let's take a
look and then like when she stops typing
just slowly track in and when you can't
track in anymore you know just say and
and like very very similar like there's
gonna be a ton of people talking over
there saying how bad it is and stuff
like that very quiet on the set Rachel
ready Rob yep and it reviews let's take
a look
I don't get it with some people like
Nutcracker 3ds surely they liked mine oh
okay yeah let me do one more go get it
some people like Nutcracker 3d surely
someone liked mine I'm again we're gonna
do a few oh wow oh the big this is
supposed to be both kind of funny and
sad so yes I said like ooh and that long
pause just okay well I like it something
really hit you and we might slowly
dissolve to like the next scene like
after you say wow which I mean go ahead
whatever face you have sort of like just
be like maybe five seconds
[Laughter]
you know we should probably explain this
so for this shot I'm just like oh I need
the room to look at things I'm just
moving bags over and we got back from
Portillo's and Tamra couldn't find us so
she thought somebody stole our bag right
from Portillo is the net has like your
insulin stuff like that she's thinking
she's gonna have to like leave the shoe
go back Portillo's or look for it might
be going forever and stuff and so now
like now we can't find now we can't find
her wig
everybody wants to see her rise
feelings are so real God thank you all
so much for making my vision of home
alone finally come true thanks for
inviting us to be in it at least I
didn't try to kill Tara
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
and Merry Christmas to everybody yeah
this is crazy this is incredible it's a
lot to take in
yeah yeah we just say I like the carpet
and like you said they have a smell in
here so nice
[Applause]
[Music]
and at the top of all of it the crown
[Applause]
[Laughter]
take a look around official we're going
to do like another video I just showing
like officially like what each room is
and when you know we got the pictures up
and stuff like that good stuff there's
like separate bathrooms now but equal
separately yeah exactly
just no smoking in the women's bath wait
yeah that are so smoking yeah and be
whoa oh yeah I swear I smell booze oh
wow it's in there gasp the gasp
I should have announced places that ass
is awesome yes I am excited we're
excited it's super super excited yeah
man like now like all the creative
juices are not coming back and I'm like
I know it's like there's so many
possibilities here right you got the
space got the signature rooms right yeah
it's beautiful
show oh no we got an actual uh like prop
and costume room rooms galore farad was
here multiple times and this place is
gigantic I can't help but to show it the
[Applause]
skeleton is natural habitat in its
natural habitat
Wow Wow
even though that's how I found out to
one of like the interviews you did
you're just like you know I'm like it's
pretty easy to talk about where the ring
I'm actually liking the idea of maybe
like somebody P cuz we have two doors
there show the size of the place 1%
pizza
this place is amazing so pizza the other
you think is big enough yeah pretty good
yeah yeah I'm the turkey from one of our
early episodes an Oreo was it well first
is it with Justin cause it's the turkey
if the turkey
that was my favorite episode of demo
real applaud is majestic okay you you
would there man you were there would
happen this thing man right we'll
just change up on the rolls exactly
oh wow that's how it happens yeah the
way it's the way of things right well
just like any other sitcom we got
cancelled after a few episodes so yeah
oh no and then suddenly we were that
sure that was a little like like well I
always kind of liked it like it kind of
got that right oh yeah it's Channel
awesome
[Applause]
you